[Music]
one thing that I wish that I told
someone that never got the chance to Wow
the first I have to say the first thing
that popped into my head and that would
be probably my friend in high school he
died in this day accident and I wish I
told him how much I appreciated him to
tell my ex-husband how sorry I am for
the things that I did that hurt him
and then I hope that he's living on
authentic happy life
I forgive you
it would be to one of my best friends
that passed away from an overdose
I wish I would have told myself
it's okay to choose yourself over other
people's happiness
I wish I would have told this person
right next to me that you should have
let me stay in California with you when
I first came to visit two months ago but
I never told her that
what I hear I am so
ah that's hard to fake I'm not going to
answer that I'd like to ask my dad why
he lived the way he did
just I'm sorry to a special friend I
wish I'd have gotten to say sorry about
certain circumstance and I never was
able to finish it no lawyer here
I guess the same I feel
please change against that
when I was in kindergarten my friend Joe
Nick I pulled the chair out from him and
he split his head open so I wish I could
have said I'm sorry I wish that after
first grade when I threw my pencil at
Paul Pinto and it hit him in the eye
that I said I was sorry and bloody and
go blind I really wish I could tell my
dad that I was gay
no I always leave it on the table
probably I just feel like I'm really shy
and quiet most of the time so I thought
we need
yeah it was a it was a gal that I dated
in college I wish I would have pursued
her with more or dignity sometimes when
someone's like about to go up to speak
and they have like something on their
face and I know they're gonna be
photographs like and then I'm like I
don't know if it's two offered to stop
them and tell them cuz they're already
in the mood and I want to get them like
out of their mood yeah just something
like that I guess it's just - my old
roommate and I would say sorry sooner
than I actually did because I think that
it would have
like so much to Friendship my cousin
Paul died in a very tragic car accident
and although he knew I loved him I wish
I had one more chance to say I love you
maybe I want to tell my wife I love her
I think that it's just like in general
like expressing your feelings like
wanting like knowing you need to say
something because it's irritating or
annoying but by neo Chun and then it
becoming a problem I guess yeah one of
my friends just died I haven't talked to
him in probably like 10 or 15 years
I was about to contact him and say
what's up and I didn't he died there you
go well yeah I'd say so but I don't know
I had you know feel weird about saying
it back in high school
I had broken up with a girlfriend
because I thought I couldn't handle her
love it turns out I could it's always
haunted to this doing
that I love you not you but I think I
would have liked to have said hi to my
grandma but I never got to meet her so
to tell my grandmother that she was my
hero and she made the biggest impact on
my life everybody probably telling my
grandpa I love you one more time before
you I wish I'd had a chance to tell my
grandma what a big influence she had on
me before she passed away I wish I would
have got to talk to my grandma before
she passed away
I just didn't want to see her in like
the state she was in so I probably wish
I would've told her I loved it one more
time I went to name Jeremy and were you
from San Francisco California okay so
the question for today is has there been
something you wish you told someone but
I never got the chance to yeah you mind
sharing yeah one day I was playing a
game with my grandma and she got she I
knew she cheated and I got mad at her
and caught up crazy old lady and she got
really mad at me and yeah threw the
cards in my face and said like don't who
you think you're talking to you don't
talk to me like that again and that were
just really mad at her the next time I
saw her I just was still mad at her so I
didn't it was like say hi I didn't hug
her and that was the last time I saw
grandma so I wish I wouldn't have said
that I wish I would I said I love
the last time the last memory I have of
herbs is me be mad at her
[Music]
you